hey this is pressure Walker this problem
was posted to Mumsnet the son picked it
up and said this primary school kids
math homework has left mums baffled
so can you solve it the Daily Mail
writes ridiculous math problem intended
for primary students leaves parents
baffled and no one can agree on an
answer so what was the problem on a
coast there are three lighthouses the
first light shines for three seconds
then is off for three seconds the second
light shines for four seconds then is
off for four seconds the third light
shines for five seconds then is off for
five seconds all three lights have just
come on together part one
when is the first time all three lights
will be off at the same time part two
when is the next time all three lights
will come on together at the same moment
can you figure it out give this problem
a try and when you're ready keep
watching the video for a solution
one way to solve the first problem is to
think visually let's have the
lighthouses a B and C and let's imagine
a time line starting at zero seconds and
going forward here's how the three
lighthouses will be on and off the first
lighthouse changes every three seconds
the second lighthouse changes every four
seconds and the third lighthouse changes
every five seconds now when will all 3
lighthouses be off at the same time it's
right here just after five seconds light
C has just turned off and lights a and B
are also off so the answer is they're
all off just after five seconds now the
second problem is a little bit more
complicated when will all three lights
come on together at the same moment well
notice that the first light turns on
every six seconds it's on its second
zero then its second six 12 18 and so on
the next lighthouse cycles every eight
seconds it comes on at the seconds 0 8
16 24 and so on the third lighthouse
turns on at 0 seconds 10 seconds 20
seconds 30 seconds and so on every 10
seconds so they will all turn on
together at the least common multiple of
the numbers 6 8 and 10 we can solve for
the least common multiple by considering
the prime factorization of each number 6
is equal to 2 times 3 8 is equal to 2
cubed and 10 is equal to 2 times 5 so we
end up with the prime factors of 2 cubed
and 3 & 5 and we multiply those together
and we get 120 seconds did you figure it
out thanks for watching this video
please subscribe to my channel I make
videos on math you can catch me on my
blog mind your decisions if you like
this video you can check on my books
which are listed in the video
description and you can support me on
patreon if you have a math topic you can
email me pressure
at mind your decisions calm and you can
catch me on social media either at mind
your decisions or a pressure tell Walker